we're all going to be
at some point in in our life we're all
going to be
presented a choice of should i read
something should i consume a certain
piece of content should i should i
believe in a picture of either that i'm
that i'm currently watching or about to
watch
i said whatever we do we have to do it
together
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
let's talk about disinformation
misinformation and startups meet dan
brahmi the ceo and co-founder of sayabra
a disinformation platform working with
governments and consumer brands to
uncover the real online
the intentional spread of false
information is not prevalent in our
society living our lives on social media
makes it easier for bad actors to spread
any piece of content with damaging
consequences to individuals government
entities public figures and brands
then brahmi thank you so much for
joining me talking about information and
the world uh i'll keep it general for
now because you'll understand what that
means in just a second how are you
i'm very good i'm super super pumped to
be here with you we've known each other
for a long time and i've been waiting
for this i've got a lot of friends
who've been on your show and uh very
glad to be here right now and
the the feeling is very mutual and i'm
gonna cut right to the chase you know we
live in a dangerous world and i think
that this is something that you're
positioned to solve with sayabra
with some amazing people on board and
some amazing investors and and yourself
of course
running the company
but really looking at the world from a
prism and a looking glass of everybody's
a journalist every the information
is all around us it's very difficult to
understand trends it's difficult to
understand what's real and not real and
in general we have limited abilities in
managing the information that is
accessible by everybody and and you're
trying to make sense of that with
sayabra working also with interesting
stakeholders and so i'm really excited
to dive deep into that and to understand
a little bit about your own thesis in
this world and so dan thank you very
much for being here
super happy thank you so much so there's
a million things we need to we need to
keep it within the the 15 20 minutes
right because uh otherwise we can speak
for hours that's that's for sure 100
percent so so yeah exactly right and you
know so that with the format so you know
let's let's start a little bit high
level you know understanding what where
we're at today in 2022 and what are some
of the big challenges
that you are passionate about that
you've decided to create sabre to solve
you know i think i'm going to be honest
for a second here and just say the
following um i stumbled upon the mission
statement of sayabra and this entire
company that we created four years ago
very randomly and very luckily i uh i i
got to know a good friend of mine named
josef who
you know
served 13 years in the army within the
israeli socom with what we call the
special operation command and uh we
became really good friends in our former
startup in which i was the first
employee and um one thing led to another
and we got to the point where um
he was telling me about this thing where
you know he he ran
a huge information warfare department
within the israeli forces um and and he
was telling me that he would like to
try and solve
a huge issue
and that there is no
there's no truth there's only falsehood
and there's only propaganda and i was i
was listening to this huge pitch and i
was saying listen i don't
i don't really know what you're talking
about
but it sounds like we're all going to be
affected by this it sounds like we're
all going to be
at some point in in our life we're all
going to be
presented a choice of should i read
something should i consume a certain
piece of content should i should i
believe in a picture of either that i'm
that i'm currently watching or about to
watch
and i said whatever we do we have to do
it together so i will not take the
credit because i'm not i was not an
expert in that field four years ago but
i got very lucky to be
accompanied by my incredible co-founders
who are coming from this information
warfare this information operations
field
and um
and you know we've we were able to to to
look at this entire world of what what
does it mean
uh the current state of the internet i
mean when you think about it there is no
real
transparency
there's no real transparency when you
and i are
are um
reading something right when you're when
you're reading a tweet a post or
however you may phrase it um we do not
understand if this has been propagated
by a real a bad or fake author
and then the second thing that is really
important is
are we facing someone with a specific
intention with a specific agenda and we
we need to understand
what is the uh what's the snowball
effect right that's that's that's all we
care about and that and when we credit
zabra you know four years ago
we said well we're not doing fact
checking because i think there's there's
no genuine way of automating automating
the process of of fact checking in an
unbiased manner and and doing it 100
automated but on the other hand
there might be a way to do what we may
call
the author checking
and the propagation checking aka
are we facing a real bad fake person and
how much of a snowball effect is being
created upon ourselves as the people
consuming
the information right and that's been
the mission statement for ceremonies
it's just to
we're kind of like a filtering mechanism
for um for online conversations this is
all we care about you know you
you said a sentence that that i want to
delay for a bit on
um that there is no real transparency
you know you know when most people talk
about the internet and talk about what
the internet has done to information
dissemination
the one of the first words that will
come to their mind is the promotion of
transparency there is no filter
everybody can say what they think and
nobody can hide anything
but your definition of transparency
takes us one one level deeper and you're
talking about from my understanding the
transparency behind not not just the
content itself but what is this content
representing
and what is this view that is being
represented and whose view is it right
and that that's where we become a little
translated sometimes because we make
assumptions that may not be true about
their author about their intentions
yeah i
i
100 agree with you i think you nailed
you nailed it uh perfectly uh when i
speak about the transparency i think
does the other does the flip side of
what you said which is also to me it's
fascinating it's when we're looking at
the the really big and large
um
social platforms out there right that's
also a point where we're asking
ourselves about the the
the lack of transparency i mean we're
looking at it's it's really like a world
where i don't know are we allowed to
curse on your show i'm not sure
maybe not i can use a weird word one
hundred percent what's not a crazy word
um but my our feeling and our experience
makes us feel like there's bad and fake
people
that are writing on the internet
and the lack of transparency
means that
social platforms in a sense
are being compensated by those
mechanisms of viral propagation
and the people who are inflected by this
it's us it's consumers
and therefore that's why we're trying to
solve the problem because if the type of
information between you and i which is
the social platform
has no real need
or will or urge to genuinely solve this
issue from its root then someone has to
do it and i'm not trying to solve a
problem that is only effective one
person or another i'm trying to solve a
problem from the outside which affects
literally every picture and every word
you might be reading or seeing every day
because we're all on our
on our phone typing swiping
listening and watching stuff all day
long
so we're all being affected by this
every second of the day
i i'll i'll go along with you and say
yes of course we're affected but who
cares then who cares
about the way the fact that there is no
transparency and this viral propagation
and this screwed up incentive system for
the stakeholders you know you're running
a startup that you know and and you're
looking to both
make a successful business and make a
positive impact on a large scale
so how do you rationalize through who
cares about this problem
this whole concept of creating sarah was
because
a i'll i'll flip the order of the things
that you said
we really are trying to make a dent and
make the world a slightly tiny
better place more a more transparent and
genuine place i think that that's part
of what we want to do
we are not curing cancer that is true
but nevertheless i could presumably call
what we're trying to solve as as an
illness it's just an online illness 100
but but but
yeah and so who cares about this first
of all us as people as simple people
like you and i
we should care about who
is trying
to skew with my opinion
my opinion and then i'm gonna get you to
the second part of my answer which is my
opinion
can be
reflected by what kind of cereals am i
going to be eating this morning
right could be tomorrow about the
midterm elections
right and it could be about and this is
funny we were just we were just talking
about how joe rogan
he retweeted and reposted what the the
analysis that we did between johnny depp
and ember heard and the crazy volumes of
like inauthentic activities and what
they were doing
and
and it's really funny because it's
around celebrities and athletes and
the cereals that you're eating and the
clothes that you're going to wear
and and yes also the elections right
they're like
is it going to be red blue green yellow
i mean yes
so there's some sort of misconception
that this information and fake news
might might only be related to oh my god
political parties and like oh my god
governments but this is such a tiny part
of the problem it is such a small party
problem the bigger problem is
those bad and fake actors found a way to
skew with every decision
and every and get like sort of getting
entangled with everything that we see
everything we consume so it's just
easier to manipulate
unconsciously
right i mean
it almost sounds like it's
you know a lot of people are get bogged
down on the details of
you know where did this start and and
what's happening here but you know
there's a saying that i love you know if
you it's this paradox
if everybody believes a lie does it
become a truth right and
this question is that hopefully not
hopefully it's still a lie and it's
still false maybe it's become a social
norm and part of the what i'm worried
about is the younger generation that you
know the way we we look at social media
today and the way it's impacting us you
know we have our values we see the world
through the lens of how we grew up with
less technology and less social media
through our upbringing today's
generation they're getting the most
fundamental you know values
from the influencers they see on social
media whether it's whether it's voice
video which can also be deep faked all
the way to text all the way to text and
and so what you're touching on is
actually you know a real issue that that
needs to
trouble everybody and uh and i'm and i'm
especially it needs to be addressed
i'm really curious then about the how do
you make a business out of it because in
order to
to you know make significant technology
progress here you need capital and you
need to show that this is actually
something that can be very very
profitable so how do you rationalize
through
a business plan in in fake news and
disinformation
yeah um so
i'm sorry so um
first of all the the reason why we're
here is because we were able to show um
they're worthwhileness and the advent
the technological advancements
sorry thanks to um the the fundraising
that we've that we've conducted all the
way from
founders fund to our crowd to accomplish
to alabaster and televentures and you
name it so so a lot of uh incredible
investors that we have on our side who
uh
enabled us to build what we believe
would be at some point and like become
this
like authentic search engine for online
conversations in a way
um
but but but the short answer to your
question is
how do we make money um it's really easy
we sell a sas product which works
exactly in that way as a search engine
meaning
people pay
for
uh uh for what we call a volume based
kind of subscription
and the bigger the outcome
then the bigger the the pricing tier
pretty much right and we usually work
with the larger organizations the longer
the larger like food and beverage cr
uh like consumer oriented brands in the
world and
some like high level uh
public sector agencies all the way from
like the u.s state department as well
and that's pretty much how it works
right it's all about
you know what kind of volume uh
you're going to consume over time
this is your pricing we did not reinvent
the will with the business model we
reinvented the world maybe with the
approach on what information
authenticity sounds like and feels like
and we
we sort of serve it on a silver platter
from a business model perspective
nope absolutely not
right
is this trivial
for stakeholders
companies different people who are
supporting this mission do they does
they understand the potential here
when we created the company four years
ago you know i think i'm going to shoot
myself in the foot for 15 seconds and
then i'm going to elevate what i'm about
to say
four years ago when we started the
company
um
he was a blue ocean but he was in the
ocean it wasn't it was it felt like a
blue pond that's what he felt really uh
it felt like it was like three players
we were just we were just going around
and we were saying hey look it's crazy
so like the requirement the need for
education was so high we were talking to
people like in early 2018
with no product
just knocking on doors and i was
listening to your uh podcast with one of
the co-founders of avo and the chica um
customer officer great guy his name is
dan by the way and so and he was like
hey
it's not about the product it's about
like knocking on doors and trying to get
the the product market feed but it's
almost like not the product market it
was a statement market faced i don't
know how to call it and um
and that's what we did and people in in
mid late 2018 they weren't laughing at
us they were saying oh yeah yes oh yes
fake news disinformation yes we
saw the elections we saw the thing uh
but it's not really for us
four years later
and you see the shift in conversation we
see people coming to us we see
cxos of huge corporations coming to us
and say
we understand that it's about to happen
and that we are all
susceptible to this crazy shift
and if we don't deal with it right now
it's not a blue pond
now it's blue ocean okay now it's a blue
and we would like to make sure exactly
we would like to make sure that we know
how to solve it so there's been a shift
of conversation where people don't
question
the need
people ask for a solution before it
blows up
that's where we are right now in the
market and um you know with regards to
the question of text versus video and
audio
you know three mediums that are you know
they're shifting in popularity and
definitely amongst different generations
different popularities how do you how do
you think through an even ability to
to create these mechanisms and these
solutions for the different platforms or
the different modes of communication i
should say right
this is an incredible question uh it's
actually also part of how we're looking
at our upcoming like 24 month of product
roadmap but at the end of the day we
started with the most
common one which is the written text
like the written content um and and we
know that that from a vision standpoint
acting as a filtering mechanism means
that we need to have an answer for every
type of medium
and for every type of publicly available
platform that there is so that nothing
falls through the cracks that we can
help
translate from the
it's kind of like acting as a colander
between the pasta and the water sort of
but you can't have two calendars right
otherwise you're missing something you
don't know you're saying wait why am i
still bleeding if it's still right
so
so today we we have for the last four
years we focused on
the written content so so more of the
narrative analysis and the topic
modeling of of the nlp perspective um
and and the next step for us within the
six to 12 months is focusing on
the transcription
from the visual content
into it into written content right it's
to say
we do know that this is a picture or
frame within the video of joe rogan and
this is how it's combined with the
written content talking about joe rogan
so that's how we're going to that's how
we're going to look at this
fascinating you know and then audio is
like
go ahead
no no i'm just saying the audio is just
it's a it's a whole new world there's a
lot of falsifications around audio we
haven't started tackling the issue we've
just started the research for this
um
but i think you'll hear more about the
audio solution from our perspective
probably within the next
18 to 24 months
i mean you know the at the end
the way we consume information it it
changes we do see some clear trends and
some clear signs and and i think that
there is also um
you know what's what's even more
difficult perhaps about audio and video
is that you have an additional layer of
of of identity right where you it's not
just
it's not just a a platform that posts
written content and perhaps attributes a
name to it
now you can actually hear a voice that
you have emotional associations with and
you have visual cues
for something that you've grown to you
know if i hear something if if morgan
freeman says anything really i trust it
right i mean it's uh that voice is from
it we all from a little kid
right and so now
it begs the question you know just like
fake bots
can generate fake information fake bots
can generate fake information with the
voice of somebody we trust and so i
think there's just infinitely many
questions to be asked here what i do
want to say though to conclude is that
it's it's fascinating what what you're
working on and the problem that you're
tackling is is admirable and at the end
it speaks about you know
really fundamental elements of democracy
and and what do how do we value
information how
do we structure information so that our
kids and our future generations can you
know have access to real valuable
information which is one of the most
problems that anybody needs to work on
um and so
thank you first for your work and thank
you for the time in this episode
no i appreciate it it was my pleasure
good to see you thank you
[Music]